il se dit tous les codes du bon football
école il en donne une fois de plus et
maintenant tout ça sans âme et j'ai
commencé à regarder du foot à l'âge de 5
ans combien j'ai loupé trois minutes et
le score 0-0 y en a beaucoup qui me
demandent comment est ce que je peux
regarder du foot 24 heures sur 24
c'est normal j'en vois pas comme ça à
remanier ses dames en voit tous les
matchs de toutes les équipes qui jouent
[Musique]
comment tu as pu chuter le décodeur dans
la piscine
tu as vu qu'ils ont suspendu le match
incroyable les démons samedi sinon je me
coupe les faits et game on samedi et moi
hôtel consulter un spécialiste met tout
de suite parce que là tu es vraiment à
cran jugement par contre ça vient tu
t'es disputé avec ta soeur et tu t'en
prends moi pas contaminer dominos dis
moi ce que tu as à me dire pedro allez
vas-y tu as été viré tu as été viré
ouais
lorsque tu as perdu ton travail est en
train de perdre ta famille un père temps
et voilà parce que tu me dire eh voilà
pedro je sais qu'il serait qu'une fille
je te dirai très bien je fais le con
mais pour le foot
qu'est ce qui t'a reilly salma c'était
pour une fille mais comment je fais pour
rivaliser avec sa wii
je sais pas faute politique font
prothétique kung fu je sais pas comment
des j'aime le foot je regarde le foot je
respire le foot j'organise mes semaines
fonction du foot le foot c'est mon
refuge qu'est ce que tu veux qu'ils
demandent pardon petit sa passion et la
passion ça se négocie pas ta passion ça
devrait être moins pedro et au refuge
cet appart pas le football mais qui ne
font pas tout voyons tout ça tu vas le
brûler avait rien brûler du tout si mes
mails ou c'est la vie je fais rien pas
de vie c'est la vie à nantes avait cet
être libéré de toutes ces choses ça
c'est de la merde
[Musique]
tu sais ce que tu fais toi que tu fais
parfaitement bien tu siffles tu siffles
du cif du siphon dire que je suis mariée
un arbitre et où tu vas je marchais tout
seul parce qu'au fond j'ai pas envie
d'être avec toi 0 choisi pedro le
football où moi je pensais pas
[Musique]